Hello,
my name is Vladimir
Grubišić and I
am an assistant
professor in the
Department of
Biomedical Sciences.
This lecture is
an overview of
hypothalamus, an
important center
for maintaining
body homeostasis
through neuroendocrine
regulation.
I will go over gross
anatomy, regional
structure and functions
of the hypothalamus,
as well as some
conditions that happen
from the dysfunction
of these regions.
The objectives of this
session are to learn
the neuroanatomy of
the hypothalamus,
the location in the
brain, and structure.
Hypothalamus is
composed of several
clusters of neurons,
called nuclei, and these
don't have anything
to do with cell
nuclei, but are rather
anatomical nuclei
describing groups of
neuronal cell bodies
clustered together.
The objective is to
learn the location and
principal functions
of these nuclei,
including the
regulation of the
pituitary hormone release.
Another objective
is to connect the
location of the hypothalamic
nuclei with their
dysfunction and
to learn about the
regulation of feeding
behavior and obesity.
To show where in the
brain the hypothalamus
is, let's briefly
talk about embryology.
this is a schematic
of embryonic
secondary vesicles
the top one
is telencephalon
in dark blue
it develops into the
brain hemispheres
and the cavities become
lateral ventricles
below is the encephalon
in light blue
and the vesicle becomes
the third ventricle
of the brain while
the walls form
into thalamus,
hypothalamus, epithalamus,
or area around pineal
gland and retina.
The lower three
vesicles form
brainstem and
cerebellum and their
respective
ventricular systems.
The brain
hemispheres of the
telencephalon
grow over the
deencephalon, so
hypothalamus is hidden
below at the ventral
side of the brain.
Now we have a
coronal section of
the human brain and
below is a schematic
to help with
the orientation.
So we have right and
left ears over here.
And this section
was taken right
before the brain
stem and that is why
that part is missing
in this image.
so these double arrows
point the lateral
ventricles and the ones
below point at the third
ventricle hypothalamus
is found ventrally
on each side of the
third ventricle so this
little bump over here
is right mammillary
body and there is one
on the left side as well
so So the third ventricle
makes the middle
border of the hypothalamus
on each side and
the internal capsule
on each side is making
the lateral boundary
of the hypothalamus.
So if we now cut along
the mid line over
here, we get a mid
sagittal section and below
again is a schematic
for easier orientation
so we are now looking
at the right side
of the brain and this
is the interior this
is the posterior we
have the cerebellum and
the brain stain over
here is corpus callosum
and right below it
is the right lateral
ventricle and further
down is the third
ventricle this oval
structure over here is
thalamus and right below
or hypo is hypothalamus
over here they are
separated by this
apparent line called
hypothalamic sulcus and
this is the top border
of the hypothalamus
Posterior border of
the hypothalamus are
mammillary bodies that
we already mentioned.
They make little
bumps on the base
of the brain. So
they also make
a part of the
inferior border.
Other inferior
components of the
hypothalamus are
tuber sirenum,
median eminence,
and pituitary
stalk, or infidibulum.
Rostral borders are made
of the optic chiasm,
lamina terminalis, and
anterior commissure.
So, hypothalamus is right
within this
blue triangle.
It is a very small
part of the brain, but
has many, many
important functions,
keeping internal states
steady and balanced.
Neurons in the
hypothalamus are
clustered into
anatomical nuclei.
And the nuclei
functionally mainly
follow this
organizational principle.
So left and right
in this cartoon are
anterior and posterior
hypothalamus.
And pseudocolored
azones of the
hypothalamus in medial
to lateral direction.
So blue is the
periventricular hypothalamus,
the tissue right next
to the third ventricle.
And going laterally
next to the internal
capsule is lateral
hypothalamus in red.
For the most
part, neurons in
the periventricular
zone control
neuroendocrine functions,
while medial and
lateral zones are mostly
involved in autonomic
regulation of
enteric and
cardiovascular functions.
anterior part is
generally driving
parasympathetic responses
while posterior part
is involved in
sympathetic responses so
for example anterior
part will dissipate
heat cool the body and
slow the heart rate
while posterior part
will induce heat
retention behaviors
and increase the heart
The hypothalamus,
speaking broadly,
is a high-level
sensory integration
and motor output
area that maintains
homeostasis by
controlling endocrine,
autonomic and
somatic behaviors.
Hypothalamus
communicates with the
neocortex via the
limbic system and that
is how it affects
memory and some complex
behaviors. These
connections also
provide a certain
degree of voluntary
control over some
homeostatic programs.
Hypothalamus regulates
visceral organs
by autonomic
innervation and through
hormone release from
pituitary gland.
Hypothalamus
receives inputs
from many
different areas.
It is important to
mention that organum
vascularum and other
circumventricular
organs is where hypothalamus
can taste if you
will the blood because
blood vessels here
do not have the blood
brain barrier as
we heard in one of
the previous sessions
for example here is
where it senses the
blood osmolality and
adjusts secretion of the
antidiuretic hormone
as i will talk a little
bit later in this
session this is also the
place where pyrogens
from the blood enter
into hypothalamic area
for temperature regulation
and cause increase
in body temperature.
A clever mnemonic
to remember major
hypothalamic functions
reads 10 hats.
So T is for thirst
and water balance.
A is for adenohypophysis
control, where
parts of the
hypothalamus control the
release of hormones
from the anterior
pituitary, which is an
endocrine gland, and
therefore it's called
adeno-hypophysis.
N is for the
neuro-hypophysis,
and this is the
posterior pituitary
composed of
neuronal tissue,
hence neuro-hypophysis.
In this case,
neurons within the
hypothalamus extend
their axons to
posterior pituitary,
and they release
their hormones there.
Since blood vessels in
the posterior pituitary
don't have blood
-brain barrier, these
neurohormones go right
into the bloodstream.
The next letter
in the mnemonic
is H, and it
stands for hunger.
Several hypothalamic
areas control
feeding behavior
and hunger. A stands
for autonomic
regulation, including
visceral functions
and blood pressure.
T is for temperature
regulation or
thermoregulation, and
different hypothalamic
areas drive opposing
behaviors to
either retain heat
or cool the body.
2S stands for ******
behavior and sleep.
We are going to move
through these different
items to talk about
the various functions
that hypothalamus
undertakes.
So now when we know where
hypothalamus is
in the brain, so
this blue triangle
over here,
we can get into
details and
talk about the structure.
We will zoom in and
first orient ourselves.
Top border is
hypothalamic sulcus.
Posterior is mammillary
body, making a
bump on the ventral
side of the brain.
Here is tuber serenum,
median eminence,
and infudibulum,
or pituitary stalk.
And below are
neurohypothesis, or
posterior pituitary,
and anterior
pituitary, or
adenohypothesis.
Rosterally, from
hypothalamus,
we have optic chiasm,
lamina terminalis, and
anterior commissure.
Again, this is the
mid-sagittal section,
so this schematic shows
the nuclei from the
viewpoint of the
third ventricle. There
are more nuclei in
the hypothalamus, but
their view is obstructed,
in this particular
cartoon, by some
other nuclei that are
positioned closer to
the third ventricle.
To find out about
the more detailed
structure of the
hypothalamus, we will
look at reclined
coronal sections of the
hypothalamus in the
following slide.
Reclined coronal
sections are
coronal sections at
the angle and they
are made along
these blue lines
over here shown
on this cartoon.
We are starting with
temperature regulation
and first to orient
you we again have the
mid sagittal section
of hypothalamus right
over here where we
look from the side and
inferior wall of the
third ventricle and
in blue lines again
angled coronal sections
starting from the
anterior aspect of the
hypothalamus and
going towards the
posterior parts of
hypothalamus and two of
these sections are
shown in the images over
here so the third
section is sliced
through the anterior
aspect of the hypothalamus
and sixth section
is going all way
in the back posterior
parts of the
hypothalamus you can
notice on these sections
here in the cartoon
that they go
through several
clusters of neurons and
over here we're
going to focus on two
the anterior
hypothalamic nuclei
and the posterior
The anterior
hypothalamic nuclei can
be thought as the part
of the hypothalamus
that drives cooling
of the body.
So if the body is too
hot, neurons in these
nuclei become active
and they signal to
drive cooling reactions
such as sweating.
posterior hypothalamus
on the other hand
gets active when the
body is too cold and it
drives heat retention
reactions such as
vasoconstriction mnemonic
to remember the cooling
and heat retention
behaviors that the
hypothalamus drives is
the idea of your air
conditioning versus
pulling on a winter coat
now the anterior
hypothalamic nucleus is just
like an AC and when
it detects that things
are too hot in the
house it gets activated
and it drives cooling
so that's exactly
what the anterior
hypothalamic nucleus does
it activates when the
body gets hot and drives
cooling by the same
analogy if the air
conditioner breaks
meaning if there is any
damage to the anterior
hypothalamic nucleus
either if it degenerates
or loses in function
due to ****** that
affects that part of
the brain then the house
gets too hot or your
body gets too hot which
is hyperthermia and
opposite of that is
driving heat retention
behaviors which is
driven by the posterior
hypothalamic nucleus
and the mnemonic for
that is when similar to
one putting on clothes
on or your hood over
your head so you can
imagine the hood is
being put over the part
back part or posterior
part of your head
so when you think
of the posterior
hypothalamic nuclei
you can also think
about putting one of
those big hoods of
code over the back
of your head which is
also the posterior
part of your head
the posterior
hypothalamic nuclei
drive the heat
retention behaviors
and if you lose
activity here
due to the damage of the
posterior hypothalamic
nuclei then you are
going to get too
cold you will have
hypothermia just as if you
lose the hood that
goes over the posterior
part of your head
hopefully this helps you
remember these two
types of hypothalamic
nuclei that regulate
temperature control in
the body now it is
obvious that both of these
sections have other
nuclei and first we will
talk more about this
section of the tree
these are paraventricular
nuclei and they are
called like that
because they are found
right next to the wall
of the third ventricle
so paraventricular the
neurons in these areas
are functionally the
most versatile in the
hypothalamus and I
will emphasize only the
three groups for the
purpose of this session
First,
these neurons
project directly
to the autonomic
nuclei of the
brain, brainstem,
and spinal cord.
So, paraventricular nuclei
regulate homeostatic
processes through
direct innervation.
Then,
neurons from these
nuclei also synthesize
several factors that
regulate hormone release
from anterior pituitary
or adeno-hypophysis,
such as corticotropin
-releasing factor or
hormone and thyrotropin
-releasing hormone.
And lastly, paraventricular
neurons also
produce antidiuretic
hormone, also
called arginine
vasopressin, or just
vasopressin, and
oxytocin, and they release
them directly into
the blood in the
posterior pituitary
or neural hypothesis.
another nuclei in this
slice also produce
ADH or AVP and
oxytocin and these are
supra optic nuclei
here circled in blue
and they are positioned
right above the
optic chiasm over
here and therefore
they are called supra
optic and you can see
in this mid sagittal
section of the
hypothalamus, that
they are also in the
posterior aspect of
the chiasm over here.
Over here, you can
see how ADH and
oxytocin producing
neurons from both
of these areas project
into the posterior
pituitary. So
they extend their
axons into the
posterior pituitary.
So we can see that
this is actually the
neuronal tissue. And
that's why this part of
the pituitary is
called neurohypophysis.
These neurohormones
are released directly
into the bloodstream
over here because
these small vessels
in the posterior
pituitary don't have
the blood-brain barrier.
ADH and oxytocin
are important for
water balance and
lactation. And a small
side note here shows
the active roles
of astrocytes in the
superoptic nuclei
in release of these
neurohormones.
So astrocytic processes
are physically moving
closer and away from
the synapse in this
nuclei, which in turn
modulates the activity
of the postsynaptic
neurons by increased
or decreased amounts
of collagens that are
released from astrocytes
so this is how
astrocytes modulate
the release of ADH and
oxytocin and we will
talk a little bit more
about the water balance
regulation water
balance in healthy
humans is so carefully
regulated the plasma of
smallality varies only
by one to two percent
in physiologic
conditions where there
is free access to water.
Changes in plasma
osmolality are
detected by specialized
osmoreceptor
cells in their
anterior hypothalamus.
Remember fenestrations
in the blood-brain
barrier over here in
these areas that cover
the anterior hypothalamus
allow the cells in
the circumventricular
organs such as
subvernicular organ and
the organ vascularum in the
lamina terminalis to
be bathed in plasma.
So changes in
plasma smallality
cause these
hypothalamic areas to
depolarize and
send signals to the
supraoptic and
paraventricular nuclei.
Elevation in plasma
smolality causes the
polarization of
these nuclei, leading
to increased synthesis
of ADH and secretion
from the posterior
pituitary gland.
These ADH-producing
areas also receive
other inputs from
the periphery,
such as information
of the blood pressure
and low blood
volume that also
stimulate adh
release the principal
action of adh is in
the kidney where it
does exactly as it
name says it retains
water and reduces
produce production
of urine or reduces
diuresis hence anti
-diuretic hormone this
action is mediated
by the v2
receptors At higher
concentrations, ADH
also potently activates
V1A receptors on the
blood vasculature,
causing
vasoconstriction, and
due to this effect,
this hormone
is also called
vasopressin.
There are two clinical
conditions directly
related to ADH levels.
One is loss or reduced
levels of ADH due to
injury or ****** of
the ADH-producing neurons
or neurohypophysis.
This is causing
inability to retain water
in the kidneys, and
patients have polyuria
and polydipsia, or
in other words, they
have to pee and drink
a lot, just like the
patient suffering from
diabetes mellitus.
This condition is called
neurogenic diabetes
insipidus because
it is caused by the
reduced or loss of
neuronal ADH production
and to differentiate
it from the nephrogenic
diabetes insipidus,
which is caused
by the kidney inability
to respond to ADH.
Another disorder is
syndrome of inappropriate
ADH secretion, and
it's again just what
it's called. the
inability to suppress adh
secretion in this case
kidneys retain too
much water so the main
result is hyponatremia
which is the main
cause of symptoms such
as altered mental status
confusion and lethargy
syndrome of inappropriate
adh secretion
can be caused by several
conditions in the
brain, by certain
cancers, or pulmonary
disorders, such as
tuberculosis or pneumonia.
It can also result
from drugs, such as
antidepressant,
anticonvulsant, antipsychotics,
cytotoxic agents,
and pain medications.
Now, let's switch
gears and talk
about the anterior
pituitary.
Anterior pituitary
is a gland, and
therefore it's also
called adenohypophysis.
The few sources of neurons
across hypothalamus
contribute to
regulation of the
anterior pituitary, and
here we briefly mention
just archid nucleus
and preoptic area.
So, these neurons
send their actions via
tubero-infudibular
tract into median
eminence and release
their stimulatory or
inhibitory factors
into vascular plexus.
And since these
vessels don't have the
blood-brain barrier,
these factors can
freely enter this
portal circulation and
be delivered to the
anterior pituitary.
over there they stimulate
or inhibit release
of anterior pituitary
hormones into
systemic circulation
over here and in turn
stimulate other peripheral
glands and tissues.
Archeate nucleus is
one of the few places
in the brain where
dopamine is produced
and here dopamine inhibits
release of prolactin
from the anterior
pituitary. This
nucleus also produces
growth hormone releasing
hormone, which
stimulates release of the
growth hormone from
the adenohypophysis.
It also has many
other functions, and
one of them is
regulation of feeding
behavior that we
will briefly mention
a little bit later
in this session.
Preoptic area is another
region that produces
gonadotropin releasing
factor and we can
see it in this section
of the hypothalamus.
It also regulates
****** behavior and its
receptive area for
water balance and
temperature regulation.
So, as we mentioned
earlier in the
session, blood vessels
around this region in
the anterior hypothalamus
don't have the
blood-brain barrier,
so neurons can taste
the blood osmolality,
and also pyrogen
from the circulation
can enter into the
brain tissue and
stimulate these
neurons, so they
can reset internal
thermostat and cause
the increase in
body temperature.
Secretions from
adenohypophyses control
many glands and other
peripheral tissues,
and they mostly follow
similar principle
of regulation by
several negative
feedback loops as
shown in this cartoon.
So, hypothalamus
integrates inputs from
periphery and then
stimulates or inhibits
release of tropic hormones
from adenohypophyses.
These tropic hormones
in turn stimulate
secretion of their
target glands and inhibit
further stimulation
from hypothalamus.
Target gland hormones
inhibit secretions
from both
adenohypophysis and
stimulating factors
from hypothalamus.
And now you can
follow this principle
on this cartoon
showing hypothalamus
pituitary thyroid
regulation.
this is a summary for
relationship between
hypothalamus and
pituitary again
posterior part is
neuronal tissue and
therefore it's called
neural hypothesis where
oxytocin and ADH are
released directly
into the bloodstream
from the axons of
neurons residing in
the hypothalamus.
On the other hand,
anterior pituitary is
gland tissue, hence it also
called adenohypophysis.
In this case,
hormones from the
hypothalamus are first
released in the portal
system at a median
eminence and they either
stimulate or inhibit
release of hormones from
the adenohypophysis
into blood. This slide
is also a nice summary
of the glands and
other tissues that are
controlled downstream
from hypothalamic
release of neurohormones.
Moving on to
the section of
the posterior
hypothalamus.
So on the left is
section number 5 and
encircled here are
dorsal medial nuclei.
Again, on this inset,
we can see that
section number 5 is
getting this little
part of the dorsomedial
nucleus, and
that is what is
outlined over here in
this angled coronal
section number 5.
So neurons in the
dorsomidial nuclei
regulate behaviors
such as aggression and
attention and also
feeling behavior as well.
And this is a nice
example how all these
behaviors are regulated
from the same nucleus.
So neurons from
this nucleus project
to other brain
regions to regulate
these behaviors.
And these are all
linked behaviors
because, for instance,
you cannot feed
while sleeping.
Therefore,
they need to act
together, and that
is why these neurons
work together
to regulate all
these behaviors.
All the way back in
the hypothalamus,
or posteriorly, are
mammillary bodies,
these little bumps
on the ventral aspect
of the brain. So
section number six
as shown here contains
mammillary nuclei
and they are involved
in learning and
memory because they
have bi-directional
connections to and
from hippocampus.
These mammillary
-hypocampal connections
are important
for learning and
episodic memory so
knowing when things
happen and remembering
past events.
Some patients with
chronic alcohol
***** develop
thiamine or vitamin B
deficiency and that
results in loss of
neurons in the
mammillary nuclei which
leads to Wernic
Korsakoff syndrome.
This syndrome is
characterized by
deficits in episodic
memory and general
amnesia which is
due to loss of
these mamilo
-hypocampal connections.
So,
hippocampus is so critical
for memory formation
that everyone usually
remembers that
damage to hippocampus
causes loss of memory.
However,
damaged mamillary
bodies are one of the
other brain regions
outside hippocampus
that can also lead to
memory loss as well.
Now let's talk about the
suprachiasmatic
nucleus or nuclei.
These are the
small cluster of
neurons right above
the optic chiasm
over here or
right over here in
this midsagittal
section cartoon.
Since they are above
the optic chiasm
they are called
suprachiasmatic. They
receive inputs
directly from the
retina, and they
regulate sleep-wake
circadian rhythms,
or in other words,
the diurnal cycle of
sleeping and waking or
******* state. So light
activates the neurons
in the suprachiasmatic
nuclei and then
they stimulate through
connections via
paraproventricular
nuclei and neurons in the
intermedial column
of the spinal
cord, they stimulate
superior cervical
ganglion cells. and
they in turn inhibit
melatonin release from
pineal gland during
the night or during the
dark cycle supracasmatic
nuclei are not
stimulated and the whole
circuit shuts down so
the pineal gland can
start release of melatonin
and in turn as
melatonin builds up it
drives the pressure to
sleep and this is why the
melatonin is sometimes
used to help falling
to sleep melatonin also
resets the internal
clock in the supracasmatic
nuclei so the
master clock in the
body and it's this is
regulated by the expression
of the clock genes
in the neurons in the
supracasmatic nuclei
Now, jet lag, and I
believe we all traveled
by playing over a few
time zones and know
what a jet lag is and
how it feels like.
So jet lag happens due
to this coordination
between this internal
clock set by the
expression of the
time genes in the
suprachiasmatic nuclei and
also in the rest of the
body and the current
daylight cycles. And
therefore, it takes
time to reset the gene
expression and all
the internal clacks.
And therefore, the
best way to fight jet
lag is to be exposed to
the available daylight
in the time zone we
are currently in.
We will talk
about feeding
behavior in the
next few slides.
Now, let's talk about
the suprachiasmatic
nucleus, or nuclei.
These are the small
cluster of neurons
right above the
optic chiasm, over
here, or right over
here in this midsagittal
section cartoon.
Since they are above
the optic chiasm, they
are called supra
-chiasmatic. They receive
inputs directly
from the retina, and
they regulate sleep
-wake circadian rhythms,
or in other words,
the diurnal
cycle of sleeping
and waking or
******* state.
So light activates
the neurons in the
suprachasmodic nuclei,
and then they stimulate
through connections via
paraventricular nuclei
and neurons in the
intermedial column
of the spinal cord.
They stimulate superior
cervical ganglion
cells and they in turn
inhibit melatonin release
from pineal gland.
During the
night or during
During the dark cycle,
supracasmatic nuclei
are not stimulated
and the whole circuit
shuts down, so the
pineal gland can start
release of melatonin.
And in turn, as
melatonin builds
up, it drives the
pressure to sleep,
and this is why
melatonin is sometimes
used to help
falling to sleep.
Melatonin also
resets the internal
clock in the
suprachiasmatic nuclei,
so the master
clock in the body.
This is regulated
by the expression
of the clock genes
in the neurons
in the suprachiasmatic
nuclei.
Now, jet lag, and I
believe we all traveled
by playing over a few
time zones and know
what a jet lag is and
how it feels like.
So jet lag happens due
to this coordination
between this internal
clock set by the
expression of the
time genes in the
suprachiasmatic nuclei
and also in the rest of
the body and the
current daylight cycles.
And therefore, it
takes time to reset the
gene expression and all
the internal clocks.
and therefore the
best way to fight jet
lag is to be exposed to
the available daylight
in the time zone we
are currently in.
We will talk
about feeding
behavior in the
next few slides.
The two nuclei that
serve almost as an
on-off switch for
feeding are ventromedial
and lateral
hypothalamic nuclei.
First let's orient
ourselves on this
particular section so
here we are looking on
the section number
four here on the incept
and you can see that
it's going through
the dorsomedial
nucleus as we already
talked about ventromedial
and arcuate nucleus
so lateral hypothalamic
nuclei are not
seen on this midsection
because their view
is obstructed by
these nuclei that are
positioned closer to
the third ventricle
The neurons in the
lateral hypothalamus
drive the feeding
behavior and if
you damage this
nuclei, for example
by a ****** or other
kind of injury,
that leads to
anorexia. so if you
damage the center that
drives the feeding
you don't have
this drive to eat
and then you have
reduced calorie
consumption and
resulting weight loss
these nuclei are also
related to alertness
so arousal and this is
also expected because
you need to be awake
and alert in order
to look for food again
if these if there is
a loss of neurons in
this area then problems
then you have problems
with staying awake
and situations that
resemble narcolepsy
ventromedial nuclei on
the other hand is our
centers where the
activity of these neurons
drive the satiety so
being satiated and
not wanting to eat not
being hungry is mediated
by this ventral
medial nuclei if the
neurons in this nuclei
get damaged by ****** or
injury or some autoimmune
response to this
part of the brain the
satiety signals will
be lost and one would
have to the constant
drive to eat which
leads to overeating and
obesity so these two
nuclei have opposing
functions and there is
a mnemonic to tell them
apart an easy way to
remember this is to
imagine you're sitting
in a chair watching
TV all of a sudden you
get hungry and your
lateral hypothalamus
activates and you can
imagine about your hands
reaching out to grab
snacks out of the
snack bowl or something
on each side so when
the lateral part of your
hypothalamus activates
you reach out
laterally with your hands
to grab something to
eat and when you feel
you don't want to eat
anymore you might imagine
that your hands are
folded up in your
lap so your hands are
moving down to the
ventral part of your body
and while you're
resting so your hands
are in the middle and
low or medially and
ventrally so ventral
medial nuclei give
the signal to stop
eating this is one way
to try and remember
these functions of
these two different
hypothalamic nuclei
and their locations
in the hypothalamus.
There is one more
nucleus or set of
nuclei that regulate
feeding and this is
archaeate nuclei and
we already talked about
it in this session
earlier. They released
many factors for regulation
of adenohypophysis
hormone release so
one of the precursor
proteins that is produced
in the neurons in
this area is pro-opio
melanocortin and we talked
about it in one of
the previous sessions
on neuropeptides and
neurochemistry so this
precursor peptide It
serves as a precursor
for three different
groups of neuropeptides.
And just as
its name says,
opioid is for
beta-endorphin,
a member of an
opioid family.
Melano is for
melanocyte-stimulating
hormones, and cortin is
for adrenocorticotropic
hormone. Now
melanocyte stimulating
hormones are important
for skin pigmentation
as they stimulate
melanin production but
also as it turns out
they are important
signals for regulation
of feeding behaviors.
Now let's take
a step back and
look at a broader
more holistic view
on this regulation
of feeding.
feeding behavior and
energy balance come
together because the
same areas in the
hypothalamus coordinate
the processes that
control feeding and the
perception of satiety
and they also influence
the creation of
several hormones
that are important in
regulation of energy
balance and metabolism
including those from
the thyroid and adrenal
glands this schematic
over here shows
how the hypothalamus
receives neuronal
signals from the
gastrointestinal tract that
provide sensory
information about stomach
filling they also
receive signal signals
from gastrointestinal
hormones and signals
from hormones released
by adipose tissue.
The other inputs that
hypothalamus receives
and are not shown
in this cartoon are
chemical signals from
nutrients in the blood
that signal satiety and
signals from cerebral
cortex such as sight,
smell, and taste
that influence feeding
behavior as well.
So feedback
mechanisms for control
of food intake are
the stretch receptors
in the stomach that
activate sensory
afferent path
phase in the vagus
nerve and they
inhibit food intake.
Peptide YY,
cholestisokinin,
and insulin are
gastrointestinal
hormones that are
released by the
ingestion of food
and they suppress
further feeding.
Ghrelin is released
by stomach especially
during fasting and
stimulates appetite.
And leptin is a
hormone produced in
increasing amounts of fat
cells as they increase
in size and they
inhibit food intake.
The arcuate nuclei
in the hypothalamus
are areas where multiple
hormones released
from the gastrointestinal
tract and
adipose tissue converge
to regulate food
intake as well as
energy expenditure.
There are two distinct
types of neurons
in these areas that
control these behaviors
so in red over here
appropriate melanocortin
or POMC neurons
that release alpha
-melanocyte-simulating
hormone which then
stimulates melanocortin
receptors in the
periventricular nuclei
and in turn activates
neuronal pathways
that increase
sympathetic activity
and energy expenditure
the activity of these
neurons is decreasing
food intake so they
are also called
anorexogenic the other
neurons here in green
produce agouti related
protein or agrp
and neuropeptide y
they are also called
orexogenic because
their activity is
increasing food
intake so agrp acts as
antagonist of mrcr
and neuropeptide Y
acts on inhibitory
Y1 receptor subtypes.
So, AGRP blocks
the activation
signal from POMC
neurons and neuropeptide
Y causes further
inhibition.
So, this is causing
the neurons in the
paraventricular nucleus
to signal for food
intake and also reduce
energy expenditure.
Now, hormones from the
periphery, insulin,
leptin, cholecystokinin,
inhibit these
AGRP and PY neurons,
and they stimulate
adjacent POMC neurons,
so they reduce
the food intake.
On the other hand,
ghrelin, a hunger
hormone secreted from the
stomach, activates
AGRP and PY neurons
and in turn stimulates
the food intake.
Single gene mutations
in these pathways
can cause congenital
forms of obesity.
Mutation in the
gene that is
producing the
hormone leptin is a
rare form of
congenital obesity.
A person with this
leptin deficiency will
not be able to maintain
satiety, and they
will have hyperphagia,
which is overactive
eating that leads to
pediatric obesity.
Loss of leptin can be
substituted by
leptin therapy.
Another form of
pediatric obesity
is MCR4 deficiency,
and this is
the most common
monogenetic or
single-gene cause
of human obesity.
Some studies suggest
that POMC and MCR4
mutations may account
for as much as 5% to 6%
of early-onset severe
obesity in children. On
the other hand,
excessive activation of
these melanocortin
pathways reduces appetite,
and some studies
suggest that this
activation may play
a role in causing
the loss of appetite
for food that
is associated with
severe infections,
cancer tumors,
or uremia.
Obesity in most of the
cases is multifactorial
disease caused
by interaction
between the genetic
makeup and environment,
and in some cases
the only option to
reduce the body weight
is through surgery.
Gastric bypass is
a surgical method
to exclude the
large part of the
stomach from the
digestive tract
and create a small
gastric pouch.
A smaller pouch
obviously feels quicker
and it sends distension
signals through
the vagal nerve to
register satiety and
in turn suppress the
drive for feeding.
There is another
mechanism by which gastric
bypass surgery
decreases overall food
intake and it is by
dampening gastrin signaling
as shown on this
graph so on the top we
have 24 hour gastrin
blood levels average
levels from normal
weight individuals and
we can see typical
cycling of gastrin release
from the cells within
the stomach wall
gastrin blood levels
are increased during
fasting and then they
drop with each meal.
So this is why gastrin
is also called a
hunger hormone because
it drives the feeding
behavior and feeding
is reducing its levels.
We can see that obese
individuals without
the bypass surgery,
so the line with
open circles just
below, they still
have similar cycling
of gastrin release
but in their case
their energy balance
is shifted So these
hunger signals,
in their case, are
causing the obesity.
At the bottom is
a line showing the
blood levels
of gastrin from
patients with bypass
gastric surgery.
So gastric bypass
significantly
reduced gastrin
secretion,
which in turn reduces
the drive to eat in
these patients and
promotes the weight loss.
Now let's talk about
glucagon-like peptide
1. Here you can see
differential post
-translational processing
of pro-glucagon
in the pancreas and
in the gut and brain.
The numbers
indicate amino acid
positions in
their 160 amino
acid pro-glucagon
sequence.
The vertical lines
indicate positions
of basic amino
acid residues,
which are typical
cleavage sites.
the following schematic
shows the endocrine
pathway for the
actions of GLP 1 GLP 1
secretion is stimulated
by nutrients in the
gut lumen and you can
see here a magnified
intestinal villus with
the open type L-cell,
enteroendocrine cell,
shown at the lower left.
So GLP-1 diffuses
across the basal lamina
into the lamina propria
and is taken up by
a capillary, only
to be broken down by
dipeptidyl peptidase 4,
or DPP-4, located on the
luminal surface of
the endothelial cells.
so that only 25
% of the secreted
amount reaches the
portal circulation.
In the liver,
further 40-50% is
destroyed so that only 10
-15% enters the systematic
circulation and
may reach the pancreas
and the brain via the
endocrine pathway,
and probably even less
because of the continued
proteolytic activity
of the soluble DPP
-4 present in plasma.
Lastly, let's talk
about the neural
pathway for the
actions of GLP-1.
GLP-1 secretion
is stimulated
by nutrients in
the gut lumen.
Again,
a magnified
intestinal villus
with an open type
enterendocrine
L cell is right
over here.
And this newly released
GLP-1 diffuses across
the basal lamina into
the lamina propria.
And on its way
to the capillary,
however, it may
bind and activate
sensory afferent
neurons, here in F,
originating in the
nodos ganglion,
which may in turn
activate neurons
of the solitary
tract nucleus.
right over here at
the same neuronal
pathway the same
neuronal pathway may be
activated by sensory
neurons in the
hepatoportal region
or in the liver tissue
a setting fibers
from the solitary
tract neurons may
generate reflexes in the
hypothalamus and
descending impulses
may activate vagal
motor neurons that send
stimulatory or inhibitory
impulses to the
pancreas in the gut's
intestinal tract.
Interactions between
the ascending sensory
neurofibers and vagal
motor neurons may also
take place at the
level of the brainstem.
This slide shows the
effects of GLP-1 receptor
agonist on multiple
human organ systems.
These drugs exert a
positive therapeutic
effect on human
brain, pancreas,
heart, gastrointestinal
tract and liver.
liraglutide a drug
approved to treat obesity
and type 2 diabetes
must enter the brain
to exert its effects
this study shown in
this figure on this
slide report that
tenocytes which are
specialized ependemial glial
cells express GLP-1
receptor and transport
liraglutide into
the medial basal
hypothalamus effectively
reducing food intake
and increasing fatty
acid oxidation and
inducing weight loss
these are common causes of
hypothalamic conditions
organized by age
Now, I don't expect
from you to memorize
all of this for this
particular session,
but I would like
to turn your
attention to two
conditions that are related
to neuroanatomy of
the hypothalamus,
which are perhaps not so
obvious at a first look.
First, hydrocephalus,
or ***********
of the brain ventricles,
as you heard in
one of the previous
sessions, increases
pressure in the
ventricles and this
increased pressure
will push on the
brain tissue closest
to the ventricles.
Since hypothalamus
resides right on each
side of the third
ventricle it will be
pressed by the enlarged
third ventricle.
Now question for you
is what hypothalamic
functions will be
affected first.
Now you can pause this
video and
answer yourself.
Would it be
easier if I asked
what hypothalamic
systems are
in the
periventricular zone?
So the general answers
to both questions are
endocrine functions
and endocrine systems.
Also keep in mind that
paraventricular nucleus
is also right next to
the third ventricle
and as we know this
particular nuclei have
many many functions as
we already mentioned
so the goal of this
exercise is to help
you really integrate
the anatomical
location with their
function another example
are aneurysms and
you will listen more
about this topic in
one of the following
sessions on the
brain blood supply.
The most common
locations for aneurysms
are along the circle
of willis and this
important vascular structure
encircles pituitary
and inferior part
of the hypothalamus.
Therefore large
aneurysms may
press on the parts
of hypothalamus
causing functional
deficits.
With that
Here we have a
summary table listing
hypothalamic nuclei and
their main functions.
Please memorize
this information
with the
understanding of the
nuclei locations
in the brain.
For the most of
them, the names
are also telling
where these nuclei
are within the
hypothalamus.
I also suggest to
learn this table in
the opposite
direction, So, know the
main hypothalamic
functions, or the
mnemonic 10 hats
that we talked about,
and connect each of
those functions with
these nuclei and their
anatomical locations.
This two-way thinking
will allow you
to better understand
the material and
hopefully remember
it for much longer.
With that, I encourage
you to use the
link here and provide
feedback on this
session on the
neuroanatomy and
functions of the
hypothalamus, as well
as some disorders
that happen with
dysfunctions of the
hypothalamic nuclei.
I hope you enjoyed
this lecture and thank
you all for listening
and your attention.